[Música]
[Aplausos]
así
[Música]
i
y tamaulipas
lugar de montes altos
[Música]
y
no
[Música]
y
i
[Música]
un lugar donde se reza mucho
y
[Música]
no no
no
la tierra donde el cuerudo no se sabe
rajar
[Música]
ah
soy duro tamaulipeco y eso me llena de
gloria
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la identidad está algo que surge a
partir de nuestra realidad interior y
que se progresa o se afecta a partir de
una realidad exterior
[Música]
soy wendy velázquez
y desde niña siempre pasaba mis días y
mi tiempo imaginando y diseñando muchas
veces eventos en donde podía yo
disfrutar de la creatividad y pensar que
podía mostrar mi arte a multitudes
me gustaba mucho cantar bailar
pintar tomar talleres de literatura y
también de música
crecí con todo el apoyo de mi madre y
con algunas dificultades en la figura
paterna
y también quizá como algunos de ustedes
sufrir de discriminación en mi caso
por mi apariencia física específicamente
por el color de mi piel y también muchas
veces por la valentía que mostraba para
representar algunas ideas
eso me hizo que al paso del tiempo me
mostrara una persona tímida y que
gustaba pasar por desapercibida
pero un día
alguien me invitó a un grupo de del
pandero y de danza
recuerdo que era lo menos que quería
hacer como pararme enfrente y poder
bailar delante de muchas personas
y acepte por puro compromiso y en mi
primer clase llegué y me quedé siete
años ahí
y desde entonces
encontré lo que le llamó tuve mi
encuentro con el arte y con el creador
de todas las artes desde ese día entendí
el significado de mi vida y camine hacia
mi libertad
al caminar hacia la libertad es un
proceso diario
pero gracias a el arte estoy aquí y
están ellos que son la compañía libre
danza
es por eso que creo que el arte es una
herramienta que ayuda al espíritu ya el
alma
a través de ella podemos desarrollar
inteligencias como la espacial la visual
la científico corporal
la lingüística la musical
la naturalista
la intra e interpersonal
el arte es un medio sanador
nos da una perspectiva de vida que te
enseña a ver la vida de otra manera a
verte a ti de manera significativa te
vuelves no solo un artista sino un
espectador de tu propio baile de vida
[Música]
es por eso que creo que es un medio
sanador
y la pregunta sera
vale la pena invertir en el arte
cuántas veces escuchamos esta frase
el del arte no vas a vivir pero es que
no se trata de una cuestión económica se
trata de una cuestión espiritual
se trata de algo que evoca lo intangible
lo que no se puede ver pero se puede
sentir lo que trasciende lo que
transforma lo que vivifica el espíritu
del ser humano
cuando hay vida entonces existe la
transformación y la plenitud y no
solamente puede ser transformado tú
sino toda una sociedad
somos
el cúmulo de la herencia que hemos
recibido de nuestra realidad interna
pero también somos nuestra realidad
externa
somos lo bueno lo malo el amor y las
bendiciones que recibimos pero también
somos el desamor y los conflictos
aquí
somos el color de la sierra todo el año
el sonido de la tambora y del clarinete
el acordeón la polica los huapangos
somos la carne asada los elotes el
mezcal también somos las flautas de
harina
pero toda esta realidad que nos rodea
nos hace ser lo que creemos y lo que
adoramos y eso
se enfrenta dentro de nosotros la
realidad externa con nuestra herencia
con lo que somos con lo que hay en
nuestro adn y entonces nos volvemos esta
obra de arte que nunca se termina porque
somos una creación única somos una
creación divina
es por eso
apuesto
utilizar el arte como una herramienta y
como una forma para la vida por medio de
él se desarrollan competencias
no se trata
de vivir del arte
se trata de vivir a través de él
hoy bifurca mos en este escenario con
nuestros movimientos lo que somos lo que
nuestra danza nos ha llevado a hacer
nuestra cultura nuestras raíces y
nuestra identidad
hay caminos para la plenitud y para la
identidad y estoy segura que el arte es
uno de ellos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
una más
[Música]
a la madre
señorías
[Música]
cambiar
pero
y
[Música]
mi victoria querido
volver
[Música]
y
muy bien
[Música]
y
y los tiempos de hoy soporta más
[Música]
tiene demanda
con 10
la victoria
ah
[Música]
bonita
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]